[Music]
on board the spacecraft the astronauts
preset the timer
enclosed themselves in capsules and fall
into a deep hibernation that'll carry
them several hundred years into the
future this is a familiar scene in many
sci-fi films but could humans ever
actually hibernate in real life
researchers interested in this question
turn to the animal kingdom where
hibernation is commonplace occurring in
over 200 species that we know of
take the Arctic ground squirrel native
to the North American Tundra and
northern Russia this animal burrows
beneath the permafrost and slips into a
state of suspended animation its body
temperature plummeting to a frigid
negative two point nine degrees Celsius
others like the female black bear can
multitask giving birth and lactating
while they're hibernating through the
winter
the fat-tailed dwarf lemur prepares for
its long dormancy by gorging on food and
storing the majority of its fat reserves
in its tail doubling its body weight
after hibernation it emerges looking as
svelte as ever so why do these animals
go to such extremes hibernation is a
necessity a survival tactic for making
it through the harsh winter months when
dwindling food and water reserves
threaten survival for many years experts
believed hibernation happened only in
Arctic and temperate environments but
more recently they've discovered animals
hibernating even in arid deserts and
tropical rainforests as hibernation
kicks in animals heartbeats usually
slowed to about one to three percent of
their original speed like the dwarf
lemurs which drops from its usual
roughly 180 beats per minute to just
around four breathing also declines
dramatically to just one breath every 10
to 21 minutes in the lemurs case and
black bears like most hibernators don't
urinate or defecate the entire
hibernation season hibernating animals
appear to stay alive by having just
enough blood and oxygen moving around
bodies and scans of hibernating animals
reveal that their brain activity has
just about flatlined
but hibernation isn't a long winters nap
as far as researchers know in lemurs and
ground squirrels anyways the animals
aren't even sleeping for most of it
hibernation is actually made up of
regular bouts of reduced metabolic rate
and body temperature known as torpor
animals can be in torpor for a few days
to five weeks after which they resume
normal metabolic rate and body
temperature for about 24 hours before
going back into torpor again the
phenomenon is known as an inter bout
arousal and why it occurs is still a
mystery the behaviors inherent in
hibernation like going five weeks
without sleep or dropping to near
freezing body temperatures would be
potentially fatal to non hibernating
species like us to find out how
hibernators are able to do this
researchers turned their attention to
those animals genomes so far they've
discovered that hibernation is
controlled by genes that turn off and on
in unique patterns throughout the year
fine tuning the hibernators physiology
and behavior for example ground squirrel
bear and dwarf lemurs studies have
revealed that these animals are able to
turn on the genes that control fat
metabolism precisely when they need to
use their fat stores as fuel to survive
long periods of fasting and the genes in
question are present in all mammals
which means that researchers could study
hibernating mammals to see how their
unique control of physiology might help
humans understanding how hibernators
deal with reduced blood flow could lead
to better treatments for protecting the
brain during a stroke figuring out how
these animals avoid muscle deterioration
might improve the lives of bedridden
patients and studying how hibernating
animals control their weight with ease
could illuminate the relationship
between metabolism and weight gain in
humans and yes more research in this
area might someday make human
hibernation a real possibility
imagine our surprise if the key to
intergalactic travel turns out to be
ground squirrels black bears and dwarf
lemurs thank you so much to everyone who
has supported our nonprofit mission on
patreon if you want to learn more about
how to get involved check out our
patreon page at patreon.com slash Ted
Edie
[Music]